each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so I'm going to assume that we're good
to go my name is Mary grey anise I'm a
senior researcher here at microsoft
research and it is my great pleasure to
introduce IRT lampion who's from the
University of Helsinki she's going to
present the work that she's been doing
for the last bits of summer six weeks 12
weeks 12 weeks on couchsurfing and
negotiations of collective privacy
welcome I li thanks Mary so yes Mary
said I'll be talking about my project
that I've done here the mice are this
summer or the past three months and this
is the first dog I'm getting on it so
it's all very fresh bear with me and
well yeah the topic you can see on
different so we were looking into
culture thing and what that kind of a
domain of hospitality exchange could
tell us about network privacy so just to
get a little bit of an image of who we
have in the audience do you have any
culture furs in the room yeah and yeah
and how about are you familiar with with
what culture thing is yeah I'll get back
to it in a little bit but it's good if
you have some notion to begin with and
as a technical note the pictures I'll
come from flickr's Creative Commons and
they have the credits there so that's
what the weird little words mean but
yeah let's get started so first thing to
know is that when I'm talking about
privacy I think of it in the in the
sense of boundary regulation which is
different from what a lot of other
people do so panda regulation basically
this notion Altman came up with in 1975
back in the year for privacy seen as
this interpersonal interaction el
process so it's not something people
would have but it's something they
actually do and actively negotiate with
one another and then also what's more
interesting for this talk is that in the
original definition Altman also points
out that it might also be some
in groups do but then later research
hasn't really been picking up on that
group side of side of the issue as much
mostly we would always be thinking about
what individuals do to work for their
privacy and activity levels of
interaction they're looking for but then
it's less clear what would it mean for a
group to engage in these negotiations
and so altima's idea is that people have
this desired state of a level of
interaction with others and then they
make different kinds of efforts to
achieve that then they may succeed or
fail but those successes or failures can
both go to the direction of achieving
too much or too little and both are
equally problematic so it's also not not
just a question of drawing boundaries in
the sense that I now restrict something
or a group restrict something but it can
also be this process of actually
actively trying to open up and so all of
this as it was created in the 70s
originates from thinking around physical
spaces and there if you think think of
boundaries houses would be an easy
example to start with so we have walls
and windows and doors and all of these
do some kind of work for what kind of
access is is granted and different
spaces at different times are used for
different purposes and and people might
have a pretty good notion of like when
when in which spaces are to be used
together and separately on and so on but
then the physical boundaries old that
one I'm not sure how much you can
actually see of the picture it's a photo
from the finnish lapland and there's a
tent somewhere down there in the area
that looks dark to me I don't know if
you can't see it but there you would
have another notion of like even the
physical boundaries don't have to be as
as permanent as as you would think of in
a building but it's something that can
be kind of flexible and temporary and
set up as need be and also at the same
time in the physical spaces these things
surfer privacy needs they're also doing
other functions so attend if your son
we're out in the woods would not
necessary be there as much to have a
little privacy from from the outdoors
but it's also protecting you against the
weather and and so and so these things
get get in the wind but then there's
more to it so it's not just the physical
space but there's also all kinds of
social and cultural ways to negotiate
negotiate the boundaries and they can be
verbal or parable as s here and if you
think of riding the subway that's a
really interesting space to see some of
that work happening where people kind of
turn away from others and towards others
and market their territories they might
place it back on the seat next to them
so that they can keep a little bit more
of an private space to themselves and so
on so it's really all kinds of different
things people do to to go about their
privacy but then how does all this tie
back to our interesting technologies and
social media so there's been worked in
applying altman's notions over to the
network domain some of which we all in
this room have been doing and think the
most probably at least most most known
part of bringing Altman to the era comes
from laceup Ellen and Paul doers who
wrote a paper about how do these ideas
apply to understanding privacy in the
network network era and thinking about
what changes once we have all kinds of
digital technologies in in place and how
does how does negotiation work out then
and also than other folks like dana and
helen is in bama have been doing other
work looking at similar issues not
necessarily from the ultimate point of
view but but dying back in and here now
they'll be more focusing on social
network services s couchsurfing
high-speed can be thought of as as one
of them and thinking back to what does
it mean that we have these profiles that
are more or less public they're they're
more or less persistent replicable
scales become different there's
mediation there's all kinds of new
things in place and there's been quite a
bit of work looking at different
different services looking at what does
it mean if we have different kinds of
mechanisms for sharing content so for
instance or last of them you can just
stream all of your listening behavior to
your profile automatically you don't
need to be deciding like I want to let
my friends know that I was just
listening to this song and then even
there we would end up seeing people
making efforts of like well but I would
actually like them to think that I was
listening with this music while it and I
was actually listening to something else
and all kinds of work go into it so it's
not like once sharing becomes more easy
it doesn't necessarily mean that it
comes easier in the sense that you
wouldn't need to go through the work of
work of privacy and here often the work
would be mostly focusing on people's
practices on the sites and in the domain
of like what what happens online and
some of it does definitely acknowledge
that these are tied back to all of the
things that have been offline as well
and often people are interacting with
the same people online as as offline so
those connections are there but then
this summer I wanted to make them or
more precise look into how do then the
efforts online and offline fit together
in the context of couchsurfing and then
also how do groups go about negotiating
boundaries so what could we learn of
looking at groups instead of the more
calm and focus on individuals and so
this brings us now to couch surfing so
just to give you some quick notions or
what it is so it's a hospitality
exchange service where people can offer
to host others typically people they
don't know beforehand in their homes or
then also request to stay with others
when they're traveling or whatever then
knead knead maybe maybe moving into a
new place like one of the participants
in my study who were going through this
whole process of moving to Boston and
then they had in the first week stayed
with couchsurfing hosts which had been
for them a really good way to get
started in
both looking for an apartment but then
also in terms of finding some people to
connect with and get get more to the
social aspects of what what's happening
around here and I'm not sure I think the
deadline isn't probably readable from
here but what they're saying is that
it's leading social travel and it helps
you to meet an adventure with new
friends around the world so while
there's this whole idea around
organizing places to say it's clearly
framed or something something more and
something where the social aspects are
really important and then another clip
so this all comes from God surfing's
website as they are reporting their
their community themselves so you can
see a little bit of the age range mostly
people in their late teens 20s 30s but
still arranging quite quite broadly and
generally somewhat balance between
genders of of participating and
forty-six percent of of the people who
are profiles up on the site are also
offering to host others so there's quite
a few people who are willing to go into
this activity that might sound somewhat
where that you are welcoming strangers
to your own home like why would why
would one do that so that's that's
interesting to know and then also what's
good to know about the site on which was
a good entry way for the study is that
they are one that allows people to set
up profiles that are explicitly about
several people so when you create an
account you have to make a choice
between being male female or several
people which like there's there could be
a lot to say about that that division
but what's interesting for this case is
that they actually are welcoming people
to be representing a group of people in
one profile which is not necessarily
what most SNS ease would do and so more
precisely what i was looking at this at
I will how do how do households with
more than one person trying to regulate
access
to both their domestic spaces and
interaction so this go go hand in hand
as we will soon see but making making
the point that it's not just about
opening the door go to your home but
it's also about engaging in interactions
with the people who then enter and then
some details about this study itself so
i was making semi-structured interviews
most of them took place in the
participants as homes so in the very
same spaces where they actually host
also the couch surfers who come and they
were recruited mostly through the
website so a screening for several
people profiles and then contacting them
to ask whether they would be willing to
participate and also asking them to pass
pass along the invitation to everyone in
their household so so just in case it
was just someone who's in charge of the
profile to make them understand it also
whoever they're living with this welcome
welcome to participate and that was more
or less successful so I think about half
of the cases I did get to talk with
everyone or almost everyone in the
household and then in other cases might
be just one one person are part of part
of the household who participated and
all in all I did interviews with 17
people from nine different households
and see gender split and 80s there most
of them were heterosexual couples one of
the couples had a daughter who was 10
years old and then there were two
households that consisted of house-made
so these were the kind of households
that come together either with friends
living together or then another one with
one of craigslists creations of like
people looking for others to to share a
house with and then about the contents
of the interviews so I wanted to narrow
in on what their experiences had been
with the site and through the site of
hosting so going through of how did they
first get started how did they create
the profile how do they maintain eight
who does that
then also how do they negotiate
particular cases of hosting when they
get a couch request which is what people
can send to others when they want to
stay with someone so who reach them who
responds what makes them say yes or no
on what conditions all of those kinds of
things and then also trying to tap into
what what had been some of the more
burdensome or stressful experiences they
had had and then on the other hand
what's what makes it fun and rewarding
why do they go on engaging with with an
activity like this and so now I'll next
get to the findings I'll be talking
about for notions of what what came out
of the analysis maybe a quick word and
have the analysis proceeded so it wasn't
kind of an open open-ended qualitative
process of looking looking at the data
reading and rereading and iteratively
coding it true definitely informed by
theory but then at the same time trying
to remain open of talking back to the
participants experience is so kind of
trying to remain true to what they were
saying and what their boys are out this
these issues was and not push it too
much by by the perspective I I had going
in with and i'll have some excerpts from
the interviews here the pictures are
again from flickr none of the people so
they are not not the participants in the
photos don't be mistaken by that and
also everyone is presented we had
pseudonym so they're not the real name
so that's just predictor and anima tea
but so what what did I learn in this
process first of all something I already
touched upon a little bit so hosting was
framed as this social activity and as an
invitation to interact so people were
primarily going online somewhat be gone
or had been driven to the side by the
knee that they wanted to actually stay
with someone themselves and then they
felt that they wanted to give back end
that way started hosting but mostly
people started because they wanted to
engage in this this activity and make
new connections and meet people and that
was driving the
all whole process and here we see Kevin
who was from one of the households of
house males living with four other
people and he's telling about the best
best times it has been so times when you
can actually really connect with the
people you're hosting and really see
eye-to-eye with them and become friends
and this was common to to how the
participants thought about hosting so
this is what what they were after when
they decided to host and then on the
other hand interestingly people were
talking all about then thinking of like
when when do they decide to host so they
got started because they wanted to
connect but then in deciding later on
whether whether or not to accept visits
the notion of like do we have the time
to do it came up quite a bit and people
would say if they were going through a
stressful or like otherwise being really
busy period that they would be less less
likely to say yes basically which is an
interesting notion goes there really it
becomes obvious that they were thinking
of this more as a hobby then as anything
else so it's something that you can
choose to do and you do it voluntarily
if you want to and when you want to so
it's not something that you would always
have to have to be saying and people
were kind of fairly cautious of saying
yes so they wanted to make sure that
they first of all had something that
they consider to be sufficient in terms
of space available for others many felt
if they didn't have an extra bedroom or
a different confined space for the
visitors that if they wouldn't want to
host but then even more so people were
thinking about whether they have the
time and energy to interact with the
guests they felt really like if they're
too busy and they just let them stayed
and that's that's no good like that's
not how it's supposed to be and then
they would be saying no but then of
course reverting back to the reason of
like we were busy it was was the way for
them to just kind of politely refuse
when they didn't want to end
when they wanted to put their own own
comfort inn in front of throughout the
list and another thing that we here see
here with Jeff and gate is the second
second coat from them where they say
that if either one of them didn't want
to host and they just wouldn't do it and
this was really common that even if
there was someone who was in charge of
taking care of the profile people
typically would not invite anyone unless
they had agreed on that with everyone in
the household and that leads the
situation also we're the ones who want
to host least often or or the least
degree are the ones who kind of draw the
boundary of how much hosting the
household can be doing in the first
place because there was a strong notion
that if someone doesn't want to have
couchsurfers in the house and there
should not be got surfers in the house
so then that's kind of our power get
distributed so like the right to say no
goes goes beyond any other interest and
then looking a little bit more to the
side where things we're not running as
smoothly we see that that's also like
interaction is also where the
disappointments come out of so Lauren
Bob where a couple who had only hosted
once and the visitors hadn't really
engaged with them and they were now
wondering like well do you even want to
go and like if we understand somehow
wrong what this thing is about because
these people were basically just using
us for the space and they felt that they
had been treated like a hotel and that
that wasn't what they were looking for
at all in in this process and that came
up in quite a lot of a lot of interviews
so well the hosts were requiring of
themselves to have the time to indirect
I also felt that a good guest is someone
who is actually interested to meet them
and we're going to know them and
interact with them and is willing to
take the time to do that instead of just
coming for the free place to stay which
is not not what they felt this should be
about
and that's kinda kind of a good way to
see the questions of too little and too
much interaction in action so people
were trying to regulate the thing so
that they would get to given level of
interaction and that's the whole reason
why people wanted to host was to have
more interaction if that didn't happen
they felt very violated of like well
this is not not at all what we were we
were looking for then to the next part
so looking at the boundary regulation
mechanisms it was obvious that they're
functioning as a whole that's something
that I was expecting going in with but
then making things more interesting is
is the way they actually fit together so
there is a clear loop of how how the
regulation goes on so people were using
the online profile as a way to in in
some ways as a baseline so they were
using that to communicate what they
wanted what they had for offer what were
some of the rules and restrictions
around like what what they expected of
the guests and then also things like how
long they would be willing to host
someone how often they wanted to host
the profiles allow people to pick
whether they are more or less likely to
agree to host and that was used as a way
to filter out like how how many requests
they would be receiving but then at the
same time the experiences of like once
the online part of agreeing to host host
someone had succeeded in the way that
someone is actually coming for a visit
people would then go go through the
hosting experience and sometimes things
weren't working or something was working
differently from from what they expected
and those kinds of things would then
lead lead them into making updates the
profile and what was happening basically
is that like once once the host had
decided that ok we'll do this they were
always trying to be very tolerant
the guests they had accepted to receive
even if they were doing things that felt
like this is not not what we wanted one
example was a couple who had received
four college students and that had
turned out to be a little bit more
overwhelming than they had expected and
the after after the visit they were like
all right we can't be hosting this many
people at once like we're running out of
water but then also it's just like it
makes it impossible to to go about our
daily lives if we have this many people
in the house female in the couple was
mostly working from home so for her
especially it had been a struggle to get
stuff done when when they had to all of
the visitors in the house so then it's
but it was the I it was interesting that
there was definitely this sense of we
won't really make confrontations with
the guests while they're there that was
more like well we sign up for this and
we decided to let these people come so
we'll just now have to somehow deal with
that but then once the guests were gone
they could go and change things for a
future occasion so the profile was used
to prevent basically from any
uncomfortable experiences from happening
and with more or less success but mostly
mostly it seemed to be working well then
coming to the part of regulating
together as a group there are clear
signs of both delegation and cooperation
so people would would divide tasks
around hosting it was quite common that
there was someone in the household who
was in charge of the online account who
would be the one who'd make me making
updates the profile who would be reading
the requests responding to them and
taking care of the coordination before
with its and this was something that was
also emphasized by the way culture thing
is designed because they allow you to
have one email address to which all of
the messages you're receiving within the
service will be redirected and then that
basically was emphasizing the tendency
that someone becomes a gatekeeper
question if you're the one to get access
to the emails then you're likely to be
the one who's also responding to them
and people negotiate
differently around how how to how to go
about it so here's Jeff and Kate again
and they were about doing this very much
together as they are saying they would
definitely always look at the request
and talk about it together before one of
them would respond they were also the 11
household in the study who had made a
hack to get around the email redirect
system so they had set up a new gmail
account to which the messages were
forwarded from couchsurfing and then
from there on they were using that
account only to then redirect to the
email addresses of each of them so that
they could actually get the messages at
the same time and have equal access
access to that but most households
weren't doing anything like that and
then they were either struggling a
little bit with the fact that they
didn't didn't have as much access but
for the most part people felt fairly
okay about someone someone taking care
of the account and then forwarding the
messages to others or filtering them out
that not only bring into like promising
ones to discussion with others so there
was a lot of what of division of tasks
in that that sense and here we have
another example christina was living
with her partner and their daughter and
she's saying she was one of the ones who
would be filtering out the requests the
family was receiving she was very much
in charge of the profile cause her
partner wasn't that keen on hosting or
was even somewhat reluctant to to do
that so she was carefully trying to pick
out the request that thought could be
interesting for John and then bring them
into discussion but she she too is here
saying that she couldn't still even if
it was clearly her task to take care of
God sure thing she couldn't go and
accept anything without discussing with
John but then also interestingly as as
for the daughter she felt that it's more
about offer
notice so it was enough to inform her of
visitors coming in apart from the from
cases where they did too maybe it's
definite to give up her room so that the
guests would stay there and in those
cases she felt like well then then she
should have a discussion with Stephanie
and get her permission she had once done
this without permission and that had led
to some unhappy discussions between the
mother and the writer or so that was
also learning learning process of like
even if the child doesn't get to decide
about the whole household and access to
like who gets to stay with the family
they could still have some spaces within
the house where they they have the rule
and then we have Jenna and Simon here
showcasing how how then once once who
wants the guests were in the home space
these household members would engage in
turn taking so jenna is explaining how
it's good to be hosting together with
her partner because then you don't need
to feel that you're stuck with the
guests you can go and do your own things
retreat for a little bit or if you need
to go and take care of some other
responsibilities you can do that without
feeling that you're abandoning the
guests are not living up to the
expectations of interacting with them
and this was quite common in different
different forms and it intertwines
definitely with with how the home spaces
were used in the census well that people
could then retreat to their home offices
or in the case of the housemates
everyone would have their own room and
if someone wanted to be away from the
guests for a while they could always
retreat back to those those spaces where
the guests weren't expected to enter
and another way groups negotiate
together comes out in in the rare cases
of there being something that comes
close to a conflict or something that
needs to be addressed with the guests
and Kevin here who was in charge of
their profile and was taking taking care
of mostly mostly coordinating the visit
so couchsurfers is talking about house
casting general he didn't really feel
that there's difference between whether
it's a friend of one of the housemates
or a couchsurfer coming in so this was a
household who was commonly when a weekly
basis pretty much receiving people and
it was normal for there to be people
around who don't permanently live live
in the house but what Kevin is saying is
that he would not go to a house mates
guest and address an issue but they
would talk to the housemate and ask them
to take care of it and a similar thing
was also happening in the household of
Christina and John that we saw a moment
ago where if jon was unhappy about
something he would talk with christina
and ask ask her to go and go and deal
with it so in this wave and even within
the home space some dedication was
what's happening but mostly though soon
as the guests we're in the home space
people would more MORE go into this
cooperative mode where everyone would be
interacting with the guests and everyone
would also have a say about what spaces
are used and how how are those those
used because it's so much more than
immediate in the in the daily life of
the household that it was basically hard
not to not to be involved and then
finally comes the part of access to
domestic space is being both spatially
and temporally enhanced we've already
seen some little signs of that in terms
of there being spaces within the
households where it would be someone's
room that they get to have a say over
even if the common spaces are regulated
differently and then also time was
playing into it people were fluctuating
in how many visitors they wanted to
receive
giving who just so I was explaining how
their household would go through this
little sprees of hosting a lot get sick
of it take a break then host again once
they felt like it was it was fun again
and there in that fluctuation we can see
how how the framing of of this activity
as a hobby comes in again as well where
if you don't feel like it you don't you
don't have to go on go on doing it and
then when it comes to the domestic space
it's also really important to be clear
about that the choice of making the home
accessible it's not a binary one so it's
not just like we opened the door and now
they're in our home but there's actually
all these new ones around which spaces
in the home are accessible to whom and
when and who's interacting with women
and all that so here we see Jenna what
was mentioning before in her experience
of hosting hosting for college students
and while they were hosting as well to
have interaction with the guests and
that was something that was valued then
during the day when she would need it to
work it became a problem that the guests
didn't realize that this is not the time
to be interacting Saudi temporality
kicks kicks in here were something that
is actually looked for and wished for
and valued at one time becomes a problem
at another one and a similar case from
Christina where she was talking about a
family who once stayed with them and was
cooking basically all of their meals in
in the kitchen and she hadn't realized
before that they would be doing as much
of it and she goes into this beautiful
line of like they were really respectful
but they were still taking up space and
time where while she was happy to let
the guests use the kitchen when it got
to the point that she couldn't go and
cook dinner for her own family because
the guests had taken up the kitchen then
it became a problem and they needed to
go into this little negotiation of like
who cooks and when and how how do how to
go about it bathrooms are another
example of
how this these things play play into the
picture where where they would also need
to be shifted in like who who's using
them and when and especially the
mornings could be a time when there was
more more demand for the bathrooms than
then space and some kind of turn taking
need to take place there too and then we
have Kevin again explaining about how
they would only want to be hosting when
when they can put up the house in good
enough shape which ties back to back to
the whole point of taking breaks when
you don't feel like hosting so there was
this effort going into being able to be
a good enough host and people would then
think about whether or whether or not
they were willing to make the efforts of
of debt to achieve the interaction they
wanted or at times they also didn't want
the interaction so that that fluctuation
was what's happening and the thinking
around what what is enough and how how
could have a host you need to be so that
you can call call people in was
something that many households were
struggling with quite a bit and thinking
about thinking about it a lot and it was
interesting or some of them were even
reflecting on it themselves like if they
had been capturing themselves they had
always been happy with like whatever
little corner was provided to them like
they would never never moan and they
felt it as a guest they should never be
dissatisfied by what is over but then
when they were thinking of hosting
themselves to standard was different of
like well if we don't have a separate
room for them then maybe that's not
enough and and a lot of lot of
insecurities and that those terms
here so I'll soon wrap up but coming
back to the core core notion so what
what was seen and thinking a little of
like how is this applicable beyond
couchsurfing which is somewhat specific
case of course there are other sites
that are doing similar things Airbnb
while while it involves money would be
definitely bouncing into some of some of
similar some of the similar issues
around how the space gets negotiated but
so first there's the notion that online
and offline are really integrated and
and at the efforts really fit together
and function as a whole and and thinking
of it as a loop as well might be
something that could could inform
understanding of other other sites as
well where things happening in both
rounds good could also not not just be
reflected in terms of what can be shared
later on say on facebook but also in
terms of like what happens actually
changes the way you want to go about
regulating the other other part and then
looking at groups there's the notion
that there's delegation and there's
corporation and I didn't really have
enough enough of households and
different types of households holds to
start addressing what that would mean
for like how how is it different if it's
a couple or if it's a familiar with
children or if it's housemates though
there's definitely different senses
around darren and the one thing that was
was clear in in this study was that
people would be thinking of it of the
home home as a whole and as a social
space much more if it was a couple who
was making it open whereas the
households where the housemates were
living tended to be more easy going in
terms of like well everyone can kind of
come and go and and the living room
space wasn't as as sacred as it seemed
to be to some of the some of the couples
and then finally thinking of access to
domestic spaces and and how this diamond
time and space place place into the
picture in once to a and all of these
end up tying together of course as well
where if someone is in charge of all of
the online online parts then that means
that there they are the ones who are
taking care of it and others others
aren't and then that might be reflected
in in how the others feel that they can
get involved in the offline of line
parts of parts of the process but I wrap
up here and open for questions just some
acknowledgments to finish up with so
wouldn't have been possible without the
participants who were kind enough to
welcome me to their homes but also
wouldn't have not been possible without
marion NC who've been mentoring me quite
a bit and all of all of the smc so thank
you for that then let's take some
questions
yeah so people would just be
demonstrative question I'll ask loud
thanks um so I'm really interested in it
especially in light of yesterday's talks
in on the norm setting that we started
to think about in terms of your
participants having different ideas they
also have edged around this idea of
being present or whatnot but to what
degree did they try to signal some of
this in the profile and how did the
profile serve as a signalling of some of
this boundary where they were seen so
yeah it was used quite a bit where like
if you think back to Christina one of
the things she had done was that like
she was being very explicit with the
profile of going like these are the
spaces there was a couple of different
options of spaces in their home where
the guests could stay yeah but yeah but
then but then going forward as well like
she was giving all this information
about the family as well and then she
had a line where she named the pets of
the family and and be after after that
line she was like if to signal that you
have read through the whole profile
named the pets in your couch request so
that I can know that you actually went
to the trouble of reading through so she
wanted to make sure that the guests
would know know the expectations and
then more commonly people would be
listing out what they were looking
looking for in the couchsurfing that
they were interested in meeting people
and and maybe list out some of their
interest in terms of the activities or
like well these are the things we could
do together and that kind of work where
they would they would make it clear but
then in terms of the space like we need
you to be out of the house between nine
and for that kind of stuff I don't think
was happening as much so there's
definitely a lot of space where like
people would be relying also on these
expectations that aren't necessarily
shared we're like well it's just common
manners to do certain things until it
becomes obvious that the commitment
that's gone after all yeah yeah
absolutely I think I had a similar
question but from the slightly different
angle because when you use the word
delegation of course my mind immediately
went to Latour and I immediately started
thinking about how that stuff is
embodied in material object mutti
reality that sort of an ax social you
know become social and moral actors in
the space so rather than online were
there ways that the kind of actual sort
of materiality the space was enacting
certain forms of boundary work I don't
keys door door Casting Eddie this is our
bedding and I don't know / or the
network like is everything open and
wireless or do they sit like just yeah
yes oh they are the network or secretary
something I asked about and most were
like no problem we of course give them
access most travelers apparently go
around with their own devices so there
wasn't as much of the sense of like do
we need to give over our computer which
i think in the case is that that was
happening people were a little bit more
more each year round doing doing that
question of course once you hand over
your laptop there's all kinds of access
to to your life that you wouldn't
necessarily want to hand over to someone
you just met 15 minutes ago or even even
to our partner in many cases I guess
would be not not happening but then in
terms of the physical space doors were
definitely something that was playing
playing into it and people felt like
it's in most cases they would have it at
least like I think that was coming up
most in in terms of bedrooms and
sleeping spaces where people were really
strict around like the guests and the
hosts are not to be sleeping in the same
space is the only case where that would
be happening that I heard about in the
interviews was when the family with the
daughter was hosting another family and
then the children could share the space
and have a little lumps number party but
then between adults that seemed to be
like something they would not not want
to do and they prefer their to be doors
and then like that'sthat's
where the intimacy talk game came up a
lot and in the there are two two couples
who were living in apartments that were
more laid out as open spaces and then
they would see like they had curtains
too narrow out spaces or walls were laid
out in ways that would effectively lead
into having different rooms but then of
course it's like audio wise and any in
many ways like you don't have that same
clearness as with the door that you can
close it was a lot of new material or
material practices that got deployed
when guests were there it was we're
guests just integrated into the existing
it's yeah I'd say so we have for the
most part they were also I think it's
partially by virtue of like for the
people who who host so then most
households already had the kind of
layouts where they would have a separate
guest room or a living room that they
could keep over to the guests and then
they wouldn't need to go into changing
their own own practices as much by
having the guests around then the keys
were another interesting thing we're
somewhere feeling like of course we can
hunt them out others not so much and
then there were some cases where the
black which is going to be with the
guests all the time so they will need
the keys which was like I think they
were consciously thinking of doing it in
terms of just to be a really good host
like that's the experience that guests
are looking for that were just going to
go and tour tour around together but
then of course at the same time that
leads to the case that you don't really
need to trust the guests because you are
with them at all times so they're not
going to be in your space without you
there at the same time not sure if that
answers but yeah it just wasn't here
disruptive dishes
yeah yeah yeah but that was yeah mostly
mostly I think in terms of times and it
didn't come up with that many households
as a problem because often the visitors
would not be cooking or then if they did
they would be cooking all together we're
like we want to make you a meal of a
traditional meal of our country's thank
you for having us stay when then it
becomes a different different issue yeah
it's something I would never do this is
very poor yeah so my imagination
starting place is kind of materiality
enacting the boundary between guest and
home owner yeah and I guess what's less
clear to me in your days is that is that
designation of guest actually a
meaningful one like is that is that it
is that an identity that the hosts tried
it try to set up for people or is it
something other than guest is guest what
are these people are they for every new
and friends friend but I think guests
would probably the the notion for that
they were mostly using for thinking
about it was people like maybe if if the
visit was successful then they would
become friends and then if the same
people came came back again and it would
be a different setup of like having
someone you know visit but but there
wasn't that much of it happening though
so it mostly yeah mostly guest I think
would be the different a were working
under then when they are the ones
how they perceive the same boundaries
yeah yeah I did picked up with them a
little bit about their experiences of
surfing as well and think apart from two
households everyone had also played
played the role of the guests but I
think what would you like to most know
about the same expectations that they
had as guest or transfer them expose as
host for the most part yes I think the
only clear thing that I can talk about
were they different where they were
thinking about it differently is that
like I suggest they felt that they
should not be really making any demands
and they should be feeling grateful and
not criticizing the household and then
when they were hosting they were much
more concerned about like are they
performing well enough as a host even if
as guests they would not be evaluating
the hosts in terms of like well they
weren't really quite like I would would
have liked them to talk a little bit
more over breakfast wasn't happening so
it's I think it's mostly most of that
that's it up of of setting up different
standards of like how but then then
again it's in many ways it is the same
standard we're in both cases people
would want to be the ones who are polite
and performing well whether it's a
circus there as a host so I think that's
yeah
common we let it to the materiality
mm-hmm exactly I'm not come surfing but
I've actually like slept on people's
couches if you know that I don't I
didn't know before yeah like what what
happened was that i was i was trying to
leave as little material trace traces
behind me yeah so you know like if i was
staying for more than one day i'm just
like clear all my stuff of the country
yeah somewhere like in the corum say
yeah yeah we did the clean after myself
in the kitchen yeah so fine so that's
like that was my approach to it yeah no
question that's sort of religious how
how does the design of the service
actually promote this ethos like people
are talking about the expectation what
culture first should do work yeah how
much is this like in the ethos or the
other people and how how does the sub
presentation of the sites of coming to
because they're saying okay we are
connecting people lungs not offering
spaces yeah how do people find it
there's did they find it change
yeah alright so go to the first part of
your comment that was definitely I think
something that goes under the common
manners understanding out of people head
of like like trying not to be in the way
of way of anyone else on in in the few
cases where people were talking about
what had been uncomfortable or what they
had not been so happy with was also once
where like if they had to get stay in
the living room if the guests didn't
realized that it's their space during
the night but then over the daytime is
again a shared space and that kind of
temporal transition happens then it
would feel uncomfortable for the hosts
like I can't go to my living room
because it's now somehow framed as a
personal space of the guests so that was
happening but then for the site
definitely there's a lot of like I think
really strong framing happening by back
out surfing around how they want to
envision it and how they want to promote
it and what kind of a picture day they
are putting forth with that's something
I didn't really look into in death I was
reading through like they're they
actually have fairly precise and
explicit lists of like if you're a host
these are the kinds of things you should
think about as a guest think about this
this is how you write a good couch
request these are the things you should
have in your profile where they try to
direct people into indicating their
expectations more explicitly I guess so
that that kind of work they're doing and
then definitely over out there promoting
it in in terms of of interaction and
giving out that framing that it's this
nice generalized reciprocity kind of
kind of community which is yeah that was
and it was coming up a lot I think in in
asking people of of how they decided to
start and how they think about the site
that they were also kinda had had heard
and learned of that that ethos of the
site and we're actually taking that is
their baseline of their definition of
what they were doing when they were
hosting
the Pope do that so it sounds like
you're saying in the interviews how much
are you hearing them reflect back on
what the site says good hosting is and
how much are they bringing so I was
thinking about South stock yesterday how
much are they bringing localized
understanding of what those rules of
decorum might be and I know we have a
message would be boring like how much
Katie's out a sort of implicit middle
class value of hospitality mmm it also
has the sense of separate space that you
know to have separately admin area
particularly says something about
somebody's about somebody's economic me
so if you can just relate how much in a
seeing what's on the site is kind of
universal and how what are the
particularity of what they see is
hospitality yeah I think in many cases
it's really hard to tease apart those to
go stabled and piecing like will be read
on the site that this is how it is but
and most had like when they had learned
about culture thing he had been true
friends and others so then it's already
kinda I'm not sure how many of them had
gone through all of the documents on the
side to to reflect back on it but but
based on what they were saying they were
saying very similar things that there
are the ones that decide is putting
forth so then it seems like there is is
that connection happening but then at
the same time those sets are our clothes
I imagine what is what is the kind of
more general understanding at least in
the states of how how things run so i
think there's this combination of
cross such-and-such a bit yeah yeah that
was it taken for granted boundaries so
actually in a mood is not from their
genital conversation yeah now here they
think somebody else transfers to her
they thought was obvious yeah so it's
Tim knows Connor yeah yeah you brought
you the tessa cruel yeah yeah and you
don't know that it's there too yeah yeah
and just study definitely yeah yeah yeah
yeah and this was definitely I think
bumping into the same problem as some of
the work I've done on facebook where as
long as things are going more or less
okay people can't really talk to what
they expect or what the problems would
be and and especially in terms of the
home space cause it seemed that the
profiles were doing such a good work of
regulating what's what was going to
happen and then the rest of like the
little that there were problems people
would get carried through that by the
sense of Tolerance like well we decided
to do this and it was a voluntary thing
so it's it's cool like it's it's
supposed to be a little challenging to
encounter this these people yeah you
should be
males and we shoot
is that never made it because I find
that one of the most beautiful things
about traveling to other cultures is
sometimes you you're somebody's guests
can you pay for everything and it's
really embarrassing and you're just like
yeah and I won't let you and it's like
oh okay so you know this is a cultural
law but you know you go to other places
and it's like well actually we expect
you to pay for everything and for us
yeah how's that written about nut is the
profiles like out serving hauser pretty
much a clear rule around like there
should be no no monetary exchange like
it's you do it out of like it's a
mutually rewarding thing you do it
because you want to and then and then
the reciprocity is is seem to be
functioning on the level of the
community like if you host and you get
to stay with someone else and so on but
then definitely definitely within the
visits there would be a lot of work of
this directly smaller reciprocity in
terms of like people wouldn't be paying
to stay but they would you had tried to
bring a little gift or make a meal or do
those those kinds of things no one was
saying that they would have had a
problem with around around issues of
money of like expectations around around
that not not meeting but yeah definitely
it could be when I think for the most
part though it's like it's it's such a
clear indication again from the part of
the site that it's like no money no
money involved everyone's in it for
their reasons which are not not monetary
but yeah but yeah we don't talk about
the money yeah yeah it's
or you just come to stay and pay for
your own food because you know yeah yeah
loot for three days yeah that's quite a
way yeah no absolutely understand that
sexy or something we'll be talking with
Mario worth writing a follow-up to this
study to look exactly into the
reciprocity that is emerging anyways
even if it's supposed to be like we're
just like nothing none of none of that
then you see this interesting way to
generalize than the direct part of the
reciprocity fit together were like you
are working under this frame of like no
no reciprocity directly needed but then
at the same time it's it's clear that
people want it to feel acknowledged and
they really enjoyed with someone brought
the middle gift or like whatever it it
may be and part of that I think is also
the issue you are a product of like if
you're a guest then part of part of the
deal is that you're tracking trying to
make it as easy as possible on the part
of the host and that's also kind of an
way to reciprocate so yeah it's just
middle class once I actually think it's
messier than that if there's a classic
inflection point to it but my experience
I mean I haven't you Scout stripping for
a decade and so I'm now just playing up
again first time in a long time my
experience with it is it had a lot of
the same cultural baggage is things like
Burning Man which was about a rejection
of monetary exchange is a valuable way
of interacting somebody and so then it
try to basically impart on it these
notions of gift exchange which I have
all sorts of class by age 7 but they're
not so clean as to be middle class
there's something messy
and i don't i don't have it my finger
ended well i think the transnational
piece and so i was going to ask them to
draw out within the emphasis on a meal
that you're making is it's from your
culture like the kind of commodification
of that earnest that's in the works here
i don't you want to speak to that but
that emphasis on it's not just making a
meal eyes make me a finish meal yeah
yeah what would that what's happening in
that moment at least in this content
magners and everywhere I come into
conflict if you know the typical dish in
your homeland is something that the
person hosting doesn't read is
appropriate general looking at anybody
visit from the UK who would make a
really amazing you know Pakistani meal
and that would be perfectly appropriate
you know thing to make in UK that I
might say it's like wait why am I
getting boiled potatoes and bread
pudding yeah I don't know if you want to
speak to how much does that come to the
fore and interviews that you did that
that emphasis is also on I don't other
miss that's me it's yeah a little a
little bit of that in its and it was an
interesting thing of people like it's so
cool to use this thing as you get to
meet people who are like really
different and all kinds of exchanges but
then actually when they were picking out
the people they wanted to host they were
most prone to want to host ones who were
their own age who shared an interest
with them and like and those kindness or
then if there was someone really cool
like if someone was doing something so
distinguishable that they would actually
like even if otherwise they would be
saying no but if there was someone who
sounded super interesting than they
might decide to do it so there's
definitely a little bit of like if we
get to host people who are who bringing
some some value based on who they are or
where they from different countries and
then add some people who were not from
the state's original states originally
and for them it could be like if there's
someone asking from their own country to
stay with them or someone who could
speak their language then I would be
preferable ghost and also you get to get
to practice your french or whatever it
it may be and those kinds of things
would definitely be playing into into
how interesting against this and like
what the value of the guest is so
there's definitely a little bit of a
little bit of that yeah during the
conversation one of them is this
explicitly stated on the site is before
you arrived find out if you need to
bring food with you then it's got it up
you may need to buy groceries and bring
them ahead of you especially this is
about moral stuff if even if your host
offers to let you eat with them you
should plan to contribute as well and
that's it yeah that's sort of an
interestingly I'd love to see the
modification of that language over there
the growth of the site yeah yeah well
this is specifically also really heavily
about the rural like the special things
you need to do to go to a world which is
ironic yeah how much this seemed to
focus on access to public transportation
or the places that somebody's hosting
all about convenience or accessibility
yeah at least it has a lot of questions
yeah that's said thats thats also like
if you would have been purposely
sampling for a different type of asset
yeah then you could you could find that
but definitely then again in the
metropolitan areas it was a selling
point on the part of the host like if
they have a quick location then that
makes them a more desirable host
I wanted to ask a theory question
shifting gears been jogging that he said
the spending up in terms of privacy yeah
and of course you did that from the
start but as I listened to it nan
whenever went through the draft it seems
like you're talking about something
broader you're talking about boundary
negotiation yeah and that's about Google
I interact with under what circumstances
will I interact with them who gets to
decide whether or not the interact who
decides where we interact and how much
we interacted that seems broader than
privacy so I'm wondering to what extent
if you think what you've timed up
talking about in the analysis and in the
findings is about privacy and how much
it's about other things that are getting
negotiated to dis privacy encompass all
of what
if ya as ya it's a really good question
because I often even in my other work
wonder whether privacy's the right word
at all goes like panda regulation seems
to be what's happening and then like
that's one way to define privacy but
then if we have kind of a more intuitive
sense of privacy than its yeah it's it's
different than then also like manner
regulation is a really precise way to
way to look at it and then yeah and I
think it does spill over into regulation
of boundaries that aren't necessarily
only about the axis or in access to to
interaction because there's also like
especially in a home space like this
you'd have all kinds of other stuff that
is connected but not necessarily the
same where like if you're negotiating
over like material resources of like who
gets to use the kitchen at what time is
not necessarily a question of do I need
to interact with the guests if they're
in my kitchen no it can be more more
around what can I do with the space yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what is the right
yeah no it's know what to talk about all
of this because some of these issues of
privacy
difference yeah yeah I almost think that
your research questions of really being
what are the boundary issues and how do
people manage that and privacy is a
subset yeah and they're which which is
made to wonder what we should the other
sex please yeah yeah labeled
the sperm is gonna push you on the I'll
do the mean because I and then I could
like I totally wanted champion your
argument yeah the most part privacy is
use as an umbrella term we're having
this conversation is about no I'll stop
there why what that white is this matter
what this value regulations that privacy
I like to use when / / the owner I'm not
sure if I would want to talk to that but
why understanding privacy also in these
terms are looking at this this side of
the discussion is useful I think even
even in just in terms of you think of
back to the online domain it so easily
gets back into this discussion of like
how how do I as an individual restrict
access to information about me and then
that's just to me seems like a very well
it's a different different issue but
then also it's a week way to frame how
people actually experience their social
lives in so far as the information is
something that is actually
interpersonally produced and ties back
to all kinds of social relations and
it's not another set of more in front
different type of an information where
the connection is a social life would be
maybe weaker though I also yeah this
this is a crown where I'm going with a
lot of open questions myself as well
around like making the distinction
between the more informational
interaction or privacy how much does
that even make sense question those to
get connected together as well and the
information apart matters in many ways
because it has implications for the
interpersonal site and vice versa like
if we only look at facebook in terms of
what's happening between the users and
is required to part of what's happening
between the users and the site and all
of the other parties in the equation
then we might not be doing a very good
job of understanding what's what's
happening and what we possibly should do
about it or how to design for either all
of that
now I'm thinking about face work and
politeness and the concept of negative
face and being the freedom from
position
the right as a word to say no this is
where my boundary stops and
you'll get to pose on anymore oh I feel
yeah kitchen is easily be read as a
challenge to negative face that wanted
our privacy and face the same thing is
face the same thing
I don't I don't think I don't think they
are I don't if yeah yeah if I get your
question I think more like maybe what
the boundary regulation aspect could
bring into the Pro Tour discussions
right privacy in terms of interaction
and social relationships is that there's
like a lot of work is looking at self
presentations and looking at the face
work and then it easily disregards the
fact that there's also like that's
happening for the sake of having
interactions and like how how does it
maintained relations and focus is kind
of overly much on the part of how do
people find themselves online basically
which is a really interesting set of
questions but again doesn't cover the
whole whole social set of issues what's
happening so then that's that I think is
kind of a rough you like this could add
into the self-realization and then
definitely also with diced i SPECT with
pretty directly if we think of the
example work having is thinking that
they need to clean up so that they won't
come off as complete slabs that's like
self presentation yeah yeah yeah yeah I
want to do that on my profile but I also
need to protect my negative face
and not true
that's the balance yeah direct deposit a
face and have a boundary that stops you
from the true date online yes massive
assault in my face of that why are we
holding onto prize i feel like if i take
altman as the point of departure and
imagine this is all about bounty
regulation i think that the negative
have you ever done negative a negative
physical did well so goth one talks
about facebook the positive self
presentations also not being treated on
then Brad and Levinson and their
politeness book do this whole there's
positive face and negative faces of that
idea of face has these two sites one of
which is self presentation and carrying
out around that other
positive regard or whatever about it but
then negative faces this premium for one
more to conclusion right morning Welbeck
so those are the places where I feel
like that can't be accomplished without
some other points of pressure than our
social so i can't really accomplish the
negative face on my own like it's only
satellite exactly that's where i feel is
that Hennessy just yeah when you're
alone you have been negative face issues
at all but you know the house it faces
you see it right because you're not
putting on a bun except for the ones I'm
advantage maybe I can definitely I feel
like we yeah but you could be imagining
negative pastry you have to be by
yourself oh there's so many things I
have to do there's good man i'm not
looking at all this message because i
don't want to know and so you could feel
it no I think it's more that I feel like
these are the rich places we go
what are the things people are doing as
opposed to privacy privacy feels like a
concept that's awfully hard to keep in
the conversation of practice when are we
doing privacy and I feel like that's
been you know naps on the critiques of
the public versus the private sphere I
mean all so this is where I want why
aren't we pushing for just letting go of
the centrality or the defining it more
precisely I don't wait to let go of it
but I have a pretty good alternators
dead really though I'm because I always
feel like I end up talking these fears
for the particular terms of negotiation
of something that looks much more I felt
like I'm doing this like I don't know
what it is but it doesn't get into that
at least it tends to give me this sense
of I I have some sort of autonomy right
as a sort of individual agency in this
that just doesn't map on to what we see
in
experiences of negotiation so I'm just
I'm more like simply give me a reason
for holding on to privacy or giving any
more I don't even know what the more
precise definition of it don't think we
know when the more precise definition
given the debates that yeah but i think
i would say that one of the reasons to
hold on to it is is that as a concept it
transcends different disciplines that
has a different regulatory structure
that actually is conceptualized as
something that is in violation of social
protocol to the point of regulation by
law and there are reasons to actually
and in terms of regulation of technology
and to think about the ways in which
technology becomes a meaningful or
problematic after in the regular service
once we move it purely to the social
realm we remove any responsibility of
the technology or broader social
structures in terms of in terms of
regulatory horses I'm not saying that
this is a I'm giving you our reason I'm
nothing it necessarily no reason for any
particular project under saying there is
there's a reason to go beyond just the
kinds of social face work that we love
to analytically work through what's
tenants about information because what I
think about yeah you know the
technological legal issues around it and
it all comes down to who gets access to
bits and bytes and I think I intent
that's been posted at into the mine I
think that's the good position one of
but your deal is it when the moment you
get long you have to think about
individual harm I know the moment you
that there's a bad Nigel I want to
individual harm kind of still come back
to information that can be used in a way
so this is the interesting thing I think
that the technology industry the
technology companies focus it back to
information as being the central element
I think one of the things I think is
interesting in terms of more of a
legislative approach and again I'm give
American centric narrative to this but
one of the things I think is interesting
in a legislative approach is that there
is a different kind of harm that goes
beyond information and that harm has to
do with the costs that it has and it
will be to the individual within a
society to lack opportunities or to have
failings that in this this is where for
example you get a brandeis notion of it
so for example the idea of shame or
embarrassment as a result of a violation
of privacy is something that is
regulatory understood I'm not saying I
would argue that technology companies
are taking it purely the information i
think that the legislative world is
taking it to some notions of
interpretation okay if in that case and
the room i just trying to understand you
i mean it seems like that case still
comes back to the harm was done by the
violation of privacy that the violent
the harm could have happened if there
had been a violation of privacy and the
violation of privacy itself can that
take a form
information about you is used in a way
that created shame created embarrassment
was accessed by somebody who didn't have
some permission to have that information
is there any kind of for example to go
back to the top they were in my space
they came to my home we don't prosecute
bad as privacy law and prosecute that as
trespassing so does it ever legally even
come down to something that doesn't add
its heart involved access to data using
the case of trespassing violation of to
your proper emanations probably should
yeah but it's not an estimate agassiz
nobody would go after an underground
keep in mind that privacy law is
information streams property yeah not
always been on time just think that the
actual privacy laws are very limited and
the thing is is that but the thing is
the way that privacy is understood
colloque would even within a legislative
framework includes violation of property
violation link search and seizure
violation includes a whole slew of those
things culturally but I don't
necessarily know that it like when you
actually look at the actual privacy law
I mean then you're down to like the
Bork law I've nicely handful
that's like they're all very in my new
show and other kind of eigen i'm getting
a seriously american subject view of
this because the thing is outside of the
u.s. there are very different ways of
understanding private on the framework
but i simply talked over for me one of
the things that goes on in the online is
that what is it
product prices
subject to these other
I feel like the kind of forced to
conform to these Perry specific
information as privacy where that
becomes a kind of information that then
is coded so if I'm thinking about a
photo of someone's home what is that
when it's posted online for the person
who's posting or the names of the
persons pets way of just trying to think
through with the concerns if if I if I
fight for shipping the frame to boundary
regulation as what's happening here in
privacy is this shimmer of individual
rights that's problematic in some ways
helpful and others granted but if I'm
thinking about individual rights is also
about boundary regulation and move the
conversation which I feel like coyotes
project basically says most of what's
happening here this could be held within
within the within the rubric of bound
regulation and capture the nuance of
what's happening and capture the sense
of group negotiation then then I I
gained something I gain something by
suggesting that certainly you know
whether it's
my couchsurfing that it concerned itself
with that regulation over and above
thinking of an individual privacy of I'm
thinking about it how is it that there
are relationships that are forming and
what's my role as a company within this
within these relationships that are
forming it gives a difference of
different sets even if not sets of
accountability
I mean it's you know it's where when
companies to saya I'm not liable for
something bad I mean I don't know this
privacy stuff but it's not a word that
ever comes up in mind of world of work
so it's very unfamiliar so try to access
it from that in so it seems to me I mean
it's interesting but in the Kate in this
case it's only like this thin topmost
layer and it's the thing that a company
could address but it doesn't get an
effect it doesn't get an intimacy it
doesn't get an intersubjective
phenomenal lot it doesn't get it all the
complicated stuff of everyday
experiences with others and so it makes
sense to me that a company says yeah we
can't get it any of that so we're gonna
do this layer that we call privacy and
that's and I think Nancy's point about
it's perhaps not the right umbrella term
because it is the most narrowest of
slices of intersubjective human
experience right so then to me it's how
do we talk about those other pockets
materiality effect intersubject tipping
like getting up and then how technology
gets wrapped up in that which is also i
think part of what Dana's initial
question is signaling is how is
technology getting deployed to set a
stage and then how does that stage get
mediated along the way and so I for me
that's why the privacy thing okay but I
hear me say I it all depends on your
interlocutors at the moment right I can
I am much more flexible about slipping
around terms when it allows to speak to
certain audiences that may not otherwise
hear what you're saying true and so for
example my steaks with the privacy work
that I do are about purposefully
complicating what legislators assumed
to include and exclude in because it's a
language like had a conversation with
them about yeah no I'm not saying that
it's actually the best analytically
exactly i think that's what i think
that's what ya Helen just for you is a
spear and who your interlocutors or and
have your point because I think that
this project fundamentally isn't about
privacy now that said talking to people
care about privacy maybe part of your
agenda is I think part of us getting a
clarity in your own head about when
you're talking to who and what language
is most helpful for thinking through it
both analytically and conversation ya
know and i think that's different down
so it's kind of how i see it as well
where privacy often serves as a term to
like then you end up in the kinda in the
community where you would want to be
discussing a lot of these things where
like even if this is kind of I guess all
of us agree that it's not really in the
core of the privacy s as dominantly
understood but then at the same time
talking back to the people who are
working with that more dominant notion
and trying to bring bring into
complication and make them see that
there's all this other stuff happening
that gets way more complex than they
already super complex issues of of how
the information and restriction of it
access to it it does make me wonder for
the pants yeah that's basically what's
what's the kind of in game of knowing
that we
complex than we hold when we're having
those more pragmatic complex what's the
what's the endgame balancing act of
those two things did you get what I me
in yeah I mean that's why I can imagine
I see the value of very explicitly and I
think you I think you do this so it has
a lovely kind of that's awesome it goes
nicely with this but being able to say
to those studying privacy your concerns
primarily revolve around information and
individuals capacity to regulate their
information because of me people's
access to it so negative things that
that becomes it becomes the entire
conversation and to be able to push it
out and say it's more complicated than
that and to koi people's attention to
all the notion that it's about
regulating access to me and by extension
to others so it's it is precisely about
invitations to as much as it's about
closing almost privacy it's not like I'm
holding my cards as opposed to I'm
trying to engage you
reading my cards like we don't think of
policies that engagement so I love the
idea of being able to say to those who
are focus on privacy is holding a hard
to say what's what is it that is the
other part of that story you know it's
other people who have cards on the table
it's it's what it is that we're
negotiates the decision to show each
other who we are what we have in those
moments of
as much as close enough we only focus
that's interesting this of course one of
lot of Auckland self disclosures like
the piased concept in relational theory
of the last 40 years you know but that
doesn't really get tight from the
country to the privacy yeah yeah I think
in some places it does if I think that
all the carnage it up what is coming out
yeah yeah so it's not just closure is
but I guess yeah I mean I guess what
what the way that it I think it comes
out to think about it in terms of the
popular pragmatic just Morris is Jamaica
de because people are self disclosing so
much as evidence that they don't care
about privacy right and that's where
people like Dana stepped in and say well
actually there's all kinds of layers to
this and of course they care about
privacy that they don't think that
exactly the same like that
think they should
I guess that's the pivot point of me
they care about access to them and to
others and that seems that's where I
have the hardest time holding on to
privacy because it's still the sense of
disclosure that can't contend with the
awareness that this closure is always
relational like knows who does it even
if it's to myself it's still to my
imagined sell this one imagined was
going to see me like all of the
population that's in the mix is really
hard for me to let go of that because I
feel like that's the actions I mean I
don't think I'd screw you and this goes
back to Till's should which is that it
all comes down to when revealing the
complexity is pragmatically advantageous
for helping somebody see from a
different perspective or when it makes
them it closes them off to not even be
able to hear you because you've now onto
a train of thought they can't actually
work with you on and that slippage that
slippage between like how you're trying
to communicate your work you know I
think it's you you make steaks and you
make decisions and sometimes they block
your face and you know I think that's
not the challenges like that I think for
me I use a lot of terms that are local
in and trying to complicate things in
ways that I just do some other people
and I think that's one of the challenges
as researchers working in this space is
eventually highly interdisciplinary
spaces which is which who is it most
important that you get to understand or
complicate things I mean there's a joke
at MSR that when all of this
conversation about social media came up
Henry comb was sort of septic goes I've
never
heard people saying complicate and mean
a positive thing I think there's some
trip that like a lot of what I feel like
I'm doing is trying to complicate
without lose and that's a very delicate
dance and I it up and I think we
will all it up and the question is
how to actually do it in the most
productive weight loss well this wasn't
my argument for jenis amusing privacy
this is my argument for in the
conversation about privacy that have to
move forward and they are through those
complications I don't think starting a
new language it's a down-regulation like
I don't I don't get it just tell me that
but I mean in in those moments where we
feel that we're moving to a threshold
where folks might be able to and I think
we're getting there be able to imagine
so even even how many people think about
Big Data like that people are even
thinking wow all of this information
that about not just me but where I go
what they're doing is absolutely
captured getting people to think about
that both in terms of is that an
invasion of privacy what kind of what
feels invasive about it and mapping it
on to other conversations like that's
where I feel we can go in you know I
feel like I'm hopeful that we I'm sorry
for them page looks like there's just
two different levels oh my god
and that one part of our job is to try
to communicate to a public in a way that
helps them understand and make correct
or at least wise decisions of your sake
wiser and correct
there is correct but make wise decisions
both as individuals and this groups and
the societies of legislatively and all
those levels we all want sort of
influence that discourse as scholars our
job is to try to increase basic
knowledge of basic understanding of
basic insight and in that regard
oversimplification is fatal but if it's
questions I would who has scholars ways
people too because when i talk to
computer scientists privacy means
something that doesn't I understand that
I understand that but what I'm to say
they don't have a word for it so we
can't go there theoretically doesn't
help either right they got the word
privacy from somewhere they've got words
that I don't know that doesn't mean
another studying it doesn't mean they're
not key issues they complicate things
and all kinds of boys they just don't
call it complicating they call it hard
right so here is the same you know some
other people's of our passports that's
our job is to invent language that
allows us to grapple with the nuance and
some of that filters out to other places
and so that doesn't and that's fine just
like that's how that's how people
specialize in expertise to make
societies we're not
that's what's supposed to happen but I
see our job as scholars as to really get
nuanced detailed understandings of
what's going on and how it works and i
would expect repetitions to to be able
to grasp all of that the way that we do
so that's why i think that it operates
at two levels one of which is to really
try to unpack and understand in way more
detail than almost anybody else in the
world wants or needs and the other is to
filter that and communicate it to others
and communicate with others and to
engage other people where they are in
productive ways but those are two
different levels that we have to move
between and I think it's really
important that we don't merge them into
one another in a way that shuts either
one down right when you talk about you
screwed up because you bring in this
more complicated language and people
shut down with a bell and get four stop
that's really important but that's that
doesn't mean that we shouldn't go over
one last question and you got none of
mine can be friction covers here well
join me in thanking because I just think
so I don't really think I think we never
use the summer
these but games are rife with boundary
crossing value negotiate so what what is
it about your domain that's made that so
is it simply is it though however I me
do we need to know I think it's not the
premise of gaming is that it's social so
there isn't a conversation that I'm
individual with a private the assumption
is that even if I'm you know playing
some first-person shooter that ups if I
have a headset on and it certainly if
I'm in some sort of network setting I
mean I feel like it goes back to the pp
imagination of an individual playing
game isn't there for a conversation on
our imagination of an individual within
a social networking site is the point of
the point of entry for autism actually
is a different issue of player which is
that most of the privacy conversations
that have hit a lot of the social media
hit because of a legal interest in
personally identifiable information for
sure and there is a as drawn by a
company as non-diverse is disclosed
correct by a game or both but the thing
is what you say that the game culture
has been flawed logic lies in terms of
the legal folks gizelle well there's no
PX you make everything up that's the
rhetoric I here knowing are you get
assist with that's that's right over
here that said I have been hearing more
and more conversation about regulating
into game stuff because of the amount of
interaction and any big data stuff
coming so I my hunch is you're going to
get serious air and I think it will come
legal frame first because of a desire to
collect that VI yeah I mean I think
that's what I'm not like I think the
entry point for social networking sites
is this an individual has some
information well that's what I meant by
power that there's a base I mean this is
that we just get back to kinda classic
economic analysis to particular data and
there's particular I value to that data
so that's driving I think gaming that's
been able to move
pio it's been making it on participation
and social networking sites they come on
sing it sing that for better or worse is
probably going to be the entry point of
this up though they're going
yeah but I'm saying that is oh god oh no
I don't think should you think a goat
properly down and sell off that data all
L is very close yeah but I think think
is where I'm starting to see that really
cranky as opposed to the animals but it
still has another it still has another
economics economic me in supporting it
still has a cigarette but then what
didn't I think you actually just
identified something really important
which is that formulation is coming from
I'm looking for you to use I really just
think you know that that that notion of
Primus I'm not saying gamers don't think
about those terms but it's not an emic
driving motion right and so then it's
really important that I guess when from
your side when you guys are doing that
kind of work it is maybe your pointed
harder are to flag that it's not that
it's an emic driving new maps from the
community it's actually a notion that
comes from a certain economic cuz
configuration I don't know I mean again
I can see with our switches right like
and I'm even thinking about when
Facebook decided to create the news feed
that they are change in infrastructure
yeah that that resulted in a review yeah
and it not previously your experience
got married and experiences bad user
yeah a privacy violation no it was it
decided to go for real oddity the real
idea was true that that was one place
where they hired see pub yeah
resistivity
pajama closer and changes the weird yeah
but i think i'm for this i mean i think
if we as I was pointing I really point
to warn her Lance arguments around but
she's a literary scholar it makes this
case that privacy are the places
politically mapped out as as where
markets in the state can explicitly go
and that's precisely make sense
so her her case is thinking about
domestic violence for a long time let's
consider that's something that's
happening domestic space at the privates
that's happening between individuals
it's off-limits real estate so therefore
it becomes something Marcus as a flip
and so I love I love thinking of privacy
is always this construction of what it
is we don't want to contend with that
becomes something if we just mark it on
then then having privacy at the ready is
something people turn to it as one was
when news feeds are currently singing to
me I don't know I don't even know if i
would guess I call that demon like I'm
thinking what did people said creepy and
usually it's creepy it's so creepy less
than privacy violation like they're
thinking what I don't want to know that
like i said about an idea i think we'll
say that but the moment the journalists
pick up sure of us privacy but i don't
know if that's because they don't have
any other frame right i mean legally we
and putting exactly can I journalistic
which doesn't man scenic yeah what's a
letter worth it intimacy because I have
been thinking of intimacy but it's
loaded in all the wrong person I just
did an interview with a guy the other
day he's a live stream or and he has a
camp you know all these live strippers
they just basically put cameras on nails
and those cameras are often in their in
their bedroom so I was talking to him
about like oh you know how are you
negotiating you know what you show what
you don't cha this anyway it came down
to a discussion for him about whether or
not people call him by his real name or
his gamer name right and he had this
whole thing about it and it was clear it
was not intimacy he didn't use that
used other words but he didn't he
definitely did it wasn't that privacy
thing it was something about